Joe Franklin?
Ira Glass：Joe Franklin？
I'm ready.
Joe Franklin：我准备好了。
It's Ira Glass here.
Ira Glass：我是Ira Glass。
Oh, you're the emcee on the show, Ira.
Joe Franklin：哦，你是节目的主持人，Ira。
I am the emcee on the show. Yes.
Ira Glass：我是节目的主持人。是的。
Oh great. Ira? I-R-A, Ira?
Joe Franklin：哦太棒了。Ira？I-R-A，Ira？
Ira, I-R-A.
Ira Glass：Ira，I-R-A。
Oh, great. Now hold on one second, Ira. Don't go away. Hello? [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Call me after 3 o'clock. I have great news for you. Ira.
Joe Franklin：哦，太好了。现在等一下，Ira。别走开。喂？[听不清]。3点以后再打给我。我有好消息告诉你。Ira。
Yes.
Ira Glass：好的。
So listen, Tony. If the phone rings, take it in the back. And then come out and tell me who it is. Just say, Joe's being with a camera crew. Just for about 10 minutes. We'll do about five minutes, 10 minutes, right, Ira?
Joe Franklin：听着，Tony。如果电话响了，去后面接。然后出来告诉我那是谁。就说Joe正在接受摄制组采访。大概10分钟。我们会聊个五到十分钟，对吧，Ira？
That's right.
Ira Glass：没错。
Well, one great thing about starting a new show is utter anonymity. Nobody really knows what to expect from you. This interviewee did not know us from Adam.
Ira Glass：嗯，创办新节目的一大好处就是完全的默默无闻。没人知道会对你有什么期待。这位受访者根本不认识我们。
OK, we're what? About a minute. We're one minute five into the new show. Right now, it is stretching in front of us, a perfect future yet to be fulfilled. An uncharted little world. A little baby coming into the world, no little scars on it or anything.
Ira Glass：好了，我们现在播了多久？大约一分钟。新节目开始一分零五秒了。此刻，完美的未来在前方延展，尚未实现。这是一个未知的世界。像一个刚出生的婴儿，没有任何伤痕。
Nobody hearing my words right now is thinking, "Oh, man, remember that show, back when it used to be good? That show, I never missed that show back in the old days, back in the first couple years before it got so-called popular. Back when it was still good."
Ira Glass：现在听到我说话的人，没人在想：“天哪，还记得那个节目吗，它以前好的时候？那个节目，我以前从不漏掉，在它还没变得所谓流行之前。在它还很好的时候。”
No, actually, I think that force, that human desire to say that is so strong, to say that "I was there back when that show was good," that force is so strong, it is so basic to who we are as people that I know-- OK, what are we? We are two minutes into the program-- I know that somewhere out there, one or two of you are saying, "Oh, sure. I used to listen to that show back in the first 30 seconds, back when it used to be really good. Remember back when they used to do all that crazy stuff? When they had that guy on the phone? Remember back then?"
Ira Glass：不，实际上，我认为那种力量，那种想要说出“我见证过它辉煌时期”的人类欲望太强烈了，这种力量太基础了，所以我知道——好了，我们播了多久？节目开始两分钟了——我知道在某些地方，你们中的一两个人肯定在说：“哦，当然。我以前就在最初那30秒听过那个节目，在它真的很好的时候。还记得那时候他们做那些疯狂事情的时候吗？当他们让那个人打电话来的时候？还记得那时候吗？”
Well, from WBEZ, in the glorious city of Chicago, Illinois. The name of this show is Your Radio Playhouse. I'm your emcee. I'm your emcee, Ira Glass.
Ira Glass：那么，来自伊利诺伊州芝加哥市的WBEZ电台。这个节目的名字是《Your Radio Playhouse》。我是你们的主持人。我是你们的主持人，Ira Glass。
OK, the idea of this show, this new little show, is stories, some by journalists and documentary producers, like myself, some just regular people telling their own little stories, some by artists, and writers, and performers of all different kinds. And the idea is we're going to bring you stuff you're not going to find anywhere else. And there is also going to be music.
Ira Glass：好的，这个新节目的构思是讲述故事，有些是由像我一样的记者和纪录片制作人带来的，有些是普通人讲述他们自己的小故事，还有些是由各类艺术家、作家和表演者讲述的。我们的想法是为你带来你在其他地方找不到的内容。当然也会有音乐。
And tonight's show, we thought that we would have a theme. Tonight's show is going to be New Beginnings. And to kick things off, I called the man who's had, as best as anybody can tell, the longest running program in the history of television. His name is Joe Franklin, and his program ran for 43 years on local television in New York. And he claims that he invented the talk show format. And I called him to get some advice on how to create a long-running, healthy program.
Ira Glass：今天的节目，我们想设定一个主题。今晚的节目主题是“新的开始”。为了拉开序幕，我打电话给了一位可以说是电视史上拥有最长寿节目的人。他的名字是Joe Franklin，他的节目在纽约当地电视台播出了43年。他声称他发明了谈话节目形式。我打电话给他，是为了请教如何创办一个长期且健康的节目。
I've been called in many times to give a sort of a Dean, the elder statesman, even though I'm still a young kid. But I've been called in to give this kind of advice to new kids on the block. Conan O'Brien had me on his first show. And people like that. There's no guidance. It's a matter of paying attention.
Joe Franklin：我经常被请去发表一些前辈式的见解，尽管我还是个小伙子。但我经常被请去给新人提建议。Conan O'Brien上过我的第一个节目。像那样的人。没有所谓的指导。关键是要留心。
Your voice, I've heard so much about the sparkle, about the energy in your voice. The voice, on radio especially, is everything. And when the guest is sitting with you, you've got to look into his eyes. Many times, you get an author on there who's begrudgingly sitting there. He'd rather be home in his ivory tower.
Joe Franklin：你的声音，我听说了很多关于你声音中的火花和能量。声音，特别是在广播里，就是一切。当嘉宾坐在你对面时，你必须注视他的眼睛。很多时候，你会遇到一个不情愿坐在那里的作者。他宁愿待在他象牙塔里的家里。
And above all, get the plug fast. Otherwise, he's worried you're not going to make the plug for the book. And I created a line, Ira, that's been picked up by George Burns. I always said, the main ingredient for longevity in the talk show field, where the mortality rate is so staggering, the main ingredient is sincerity. And once you learn to fake that, then you got it made. I made that up. And I just played it by ear. I was a natural born talker, I guess.
Joe Franklin：最重要的是，赶紧让他做宣传。否则，他会担心你没能为他的书做宣传。我创造了一句台词，Ira，后来被George Burns引用了。我总是说，谈话节目领域长寿的主要秘诀——这个领域的死亡率高得惊人——主要秘诀就是真诚。一旦你学会了伪装真诚，你就成功了。那是我编的。我只是随机应变。我想我是一个天生的演说家。
So let me just summarize what I'm getting from you. You're saying you should just pay attention, look people in the eye, be sincere when I'm on the air, get in the plug early.
Ira Glass：那让我总结一下我从你这儿得到的信息。你是说应该多留心，看着人们的眼睛，直播时要真诚，尽早进行宣传。
That's the key. And don't look in their nose or their belly button. Look right in the eye. Eye contact is everything. And as I say, it's a lot of fun.
Joe Franklin：那才是关键。而且不要盯着他们的鼻子或肚脐。要直视眼睛。眼神交流就是一切。正如我所说，这很有趣。
And I never called anybody in my life to come on to my show. And I'm sure that they'll be coming to you too. I heard about you, and I called you and wanted to wish you good look, Ira. Imagine the thrill of John F. Kennedy walking into my studio. Richard Nixon. Ronald Reagan, five times. And Bing Crosby.
Joe Franklin：我这辈子从没请过任何人上我的节目。我相信他们也会主动来找你。我听说过你，所以我打电话给你，想祝你好运，Ira。想象一下John F. Kennedy走进我演播室的激动时刻。Richard Nixon。Ronald Reagan，五次。还有Bing Crosby。
And I've got a major book out right now, by the way, Ira, called Up Late with Joe Franklin from Simon & Schuster. And if you find a copy in the store--
Joe Franklin：顺便提一下，Ira，我现在有一本重要的书出版了，叫《Up Late with Joe Franklin》，由Simon & Schuster出版。如果你在店里看到一本——
You see now, I guess I've sort of messed that one up, because I didn't let you get in your plug early.
Ira Glass：你看，我想我把那件事搞砸了，因为我没让你尽早做宣传。
See, that is my fault. I got it in toward the bitter end. It's like Duke Ellington. He always used to have his dessert at the beginning of the meal. Duke Ellington said, because he would never have no room for it at the end. So he had his dessert at the beginning. Who is it? Well, no, good news, 6 o'clock.
Joe Franklin：看，那是我的错。我在最后关头才说出来。这就像Duke Ellington。他总是先吃甜点。Duke Ellington说，因为他最后吃不下。所以他先吃甜点。是谁啊？哦，不，好消息，6点钟。
Well, Joe Franklin, thank you very much for being with us on our premier show.
Ira Glass：好了，Joe Franklin，非常感谢你参加我们的首播节目。
Ira, I'm going to be a listener and a fan. And let's always be in touch.
Joe Franklin：Ira，我会成为你的听众和粉丝的。让我们保持联系。
[MUSIC - "DESTINATION MOON" BY DINAH WASHINGTON]
Joe Franklin：[音乐 - Dinah Washington的“DESTINATION MOON”]
All right, Your Radio Playhouse. All right. I'm making eye contact with you right-- wait, how does Joe put it? Wait a second.
Ira Glass：好了，《Your Radio Playhouse》。好了。我正与你进行眼神交流——等等，Joe是怎么说的？等一下。
Look right in the eye. Eye contact is everything.
Joe Franklin：直视眼睛。眼神交流就是一切。
I am making eye contact with you right now. That is just how much I have already learned. OK, so the thing about new beginnings is that there are the ones that we actually undertake and then there are the ones that we just wish for. And the ones that we wish for pretty much outnumber the ones that we really undertake.
Ira Glass：我现在正与你进行眼神交流。我学到的就是这些。好的，关于新的开始，有些是我们真正着手去做的，而有些是我们只是在心里祈求的。而那些我们心里祈求的，数量远多于我们真正着手去做的。
Well, Kevin Kelly spent most of his twenties wandering around Asia. He was basically wandering around as a freelance photographer. And he found himself photographing a lot of religious ceremonies and drawn to religious ceremonies of all sorts. And he says that he was really confused about what he believed. And he was the kind of person who had always dreamt about a new beginning, where he wouldn't struggle with these questions.
Ira Glass：Kevin Kelly在他二十多岁时大部分时间都在亚洲游荡。他基本上是以自由摄影师的身份四处游荡。他发现自己拍摄了很多宗教仪式，并被各种各样的宗教仪式所吸引。他说他对自己的信仰感到非常困惑。他一直梦想着一个新的开始，在那里他不必为这些问题而挣扎。
I would get twisted and caught up. And these things were in the background, consuming me. And actually, I found that I could think about little else for many, many months, that behind all that I was doing, there was always this unresolved question of was God real. And if he was real, then how could we ignore him? And if we were trying to not ignore him, what would we do? And if he was real, then what about these other things that people said about God?
Kevin Kelly：我会变得纠结和深陷其中。这些问题一直在背景中折磨着我。实际上，我发现好几个月里我几乎无法思考其他事情，我所做的一切背后，始终都有这个未解的疑问：上帝是真的吗？如果他是真的，那我们怎么能忽视他？如果我们试图不去忽视他，我们该怎么做？如果他是真的，那人们关于上帝的其他说法又是怎么回事？
We will not attempt to answer these questions, by the way, in this hour. I just want to just give you a sense of scope here, just modest scope. But what we want to talk about is what happened to Kevin Kelly. What happened is that at the age of 27, all of this changed when he came into Jerusalem on the eve of Easter and Passover. It was the same weekend. And flocks of people are coming into the city.
Ira Glass：顺便说一下，在这个小时里，我们不会试图回答这些问题。我只是想让你感受一下主题的范围，适度的范围。但我们要谈论的是Kevin Kelly身上发生了什么。事情是这样的，27岁那年，当他在复活节和逾越节前夕来到耶路撒冷时，一切都改变了。那是同一个周末。成群结队的人涌入城市。
So I entered Jerusalem on Easter with a simple expectation that I was going to photograph another religious ceremony, another religious festival. And then, for various reasons, I got locked out of my hostel room. They had a curfew. And I didn't make it back in time. And I was in quite a fix because I was a stranger in this very strange town. When it happened, I didn't have enough money to stay elsewhere, nor did I even have knowledge of where to go.
Kevin Kelly：所以我在复活节那天进入耶路撒冷，简单地期待着拍摄另一个宗教仪式，另一个宗教节日。然后，由于各种原因，我的旅舍房间被锁住了。他们实行宵禁。我没能及时赶回。我陷入了困境，因为我是在这个极其陌生的城市里的陌生人。发生的时候，我没有足够的钱住在别处，甚至不知道该去哪里。
So I wandered the Old Town of Jerusalem at night, which had been shuttered up and was like a time machine. It was as if I had been transported back to the 15th century, because all the souvenir vendors were gone, and what was left were the labyrinthian paths of cobbled passageways. And I wandered around for a number of hours, and it was getting colder. Eventually, I found myself at the one place that was still open, which was some of the churches. And particularly, after wandering around until about 2:00 or 3:00 in the morning, I finally settled into the Church of the Holy Scepter, which is called and viewed as the church built over the mound where Jesus Christ was crucified.
Kevin Kelly：所以我晚上游荡在耶路撒冷老城，它已经关门了，就像一台时间机器。仿佛我被传送回了15世纪，所有的纪念品商贩都消失了，剩下的是布满鹅卵石的迷宫般的通道。我游荡了几个小时，天气越来越冷。最后，我发现自己来到了唯一还开放的地方，也就是一些教堂。特别是，在凌晨两三点左右游荡之后，我终于在圣墓教堂安顿下来，也就是被视为建在耶稣基督被钉死在十字架上的土丘之上的教堂。
And I was getting very tired. And there weren't many people around. And so eventually, I laid myself out on about the only flat area that was left, which was this marble slab underneath some pendants that had incense on them. And this was presumably the slab that commemorated the exact positioning of the crosses. So I slept there. I slept on the crucifixion spot on that night because it was the only place-- they had no place in the inn.
Kevin Kelly：我非常累。周围没有太多人。于是最后，我躺在了唯一剩下的平坦区域上，也就是一些挂着香炉的吊灯下的一块大理石板。据推测，这块石板纪念的是十字架的确切位置。所以我睡在那里。那天晚上我睡在钉死十字架的地方，因为没有别的地方可去，旅店没有空房。
I slept there until early morning, when the activity started to increase, and people started coming in. And I went out and followed the crowd where it was going when they were going out to the tombs area in Jerusalem. And I went out. And there were some folding chairs set up in front of this tomb area. And as the sun was coming up on that Easter morning, I was staring at empty tombs. And for a reason that I can not comprehend, as I sat on that chair contemplating this view of the early sun morning coming into the empty tombs, all that I had been wrestling with for the past many, many years in thinking about religion sort of became resolved in my mind. And at that very moment, I believed that Jesus Christ had, indeed, risen from those tombs.
Kevin Kelly：我一直睡到清晨，活动开始增多，人们开始涌入。我走出去，跟着人群走向耶路撒冷的墓地。我出去了。墓地前放着一些折叠椅。当复活节早晨太阳升起时，我盯着空荡荡的坟墓。出于某种我无法理解的原因，当我坐在椅子上凝视着晨光照进空坟墓的景象时，过去许多年来我一直在思考的关于宗教的所有挣扎都在心中得到了解决。那一刻，我相信耶稣基督确实从那些坟墓中复活了。
In an instant, the tension of trying to figure things out was resolved, because now, suddenly, everything was figured out. It was as if you had been working on a problem for a long time and suddenly the answer was there. And it was very clear that was the answer. And although there were many things that were still not clear to you, you were very certain that you were on the right path.
Kevin Kelly：刹那间，试图弄清楚事情真相的紧张感消失了，因为现在，一切都清楚了。仿佛你一直在研究一个难题，突然答案就出现了。而且很清楚那就是答案。虽然有很多事情你仍然不明白，但你非常确定自己走在正确的道路上。
Having that realization that I believe that Jesus Christ had actually risen from those tombs did not settle 1,001 other things about what one was supposed to do with that, what I was supposed to do with that. Did that mean I was supposed to be a monk? Did that mean I was supposed to be an evangelist?
Kevin Kelly：意识到我相信耶稣基督真的从那些坟墓中复活了，并没有解决关于一个人应该如何利用这个事实的其他一千零一个问题。这意味着我应该成为一名僧侣吗？这意味着我应该成为一名传道者吗？
Did that mean that I had to immediately renounce all that I had, and get into sackcloths and ashes, and march out into the desert? All that was left unopened. And that is, in fact, what occupied my mind as I went back to my hostel to lay down and think about. Because I had no clue what it really meant to me ultimately, and that's what I was pondering when I was laying there napping. And I wouldn't say it was a voice, but there was an idea that came into my mind that just would not go away, and that was that I should live as if I would die in six months, that I should really, truly live. And that I could not tell for certain whether I would really die, but that either way, I should live as if I was going to die. And so that was the assignment.
Kevin Kelly：这意味着我必须立即放弃我拥有的一切，穿上麻衣灰烬，走进沙漠吗？所有这些问题都悬而未决。而这正是当我回到旅舍躺下思考时占据我大脑的内容。因为我根本不知道这对我是什么终极意义，这就是我小憩时琢磨的事情。我不会说那是某种声音，但有一个念头出现在我的脑海里，挥之不去，那就是我应该像只剩下六个月生命那样活着，我应该真正地、切实地活着。我不确定我是否真的会死，但无论如何，我都应该像我就要死了一样活着。这就是那个任务。
I'm a pretty rational person. I'm pretty logical. And after thinking the thought that I should live as if I was going to die in six months, the first thought that comes to my head was, "Well, that's pretty silly. I have no evidence whatsoever. I could live like I'm going to die in six months and not die at all. It would just be an interesting exercise."
Kevin Kelly：我是一个相当理性的人。我相当合乎逻辑。在想到我应该像六个月后就要死那样活着之后，我脑子里出现的第一个念头是：“嗯，那太傻了。我没有任何证据。我可能像六个月后就要死那样活着，结果却根本没死。那只会是一个有趣的练习。”
But at the same time, it was equally probable that I might die in six months. It happened all the time. There was no guarantee that I wouldn't die. And so fairly quickly, I decided that I could not settle that issue of whether I would really die or not, or just think that I was going to die in six months, and that, in either case, the important thing was to live as if I really believed that I was going to die in six months, which is what I set out to do.
Kevin Kelly：但与此同时，我也很有可能在六个月后死去。这种事随时都在发生。没有任何保证我不会死。所以很快，我决定我无法解决关于我是否真的会死的问题，或者只是认为我六个月后会死，无论哪种情况，重要的是像我真的相信自己六个月后会死那样生活，这就是我着手去做的事情。
The next couple days, I had the joyous experience of saying to myself, "OK, what do I do for six months if I have only six months to live?" And the answers to that surprised me as much as the assignment, because after thinking that through and contemplating it, the conclusion that I came to was that what I wanted to do for six months was to go home and be ordinary, to go back to my parents, to help them take out the trash, and trim the hedges, and move furniture around, and to be with them. And I was really shocked by that, because I thought that with six months to live, I would climb Mount Everest, or I would go scuba diving to the depths of the ocean, or get in a speedboat and see how fast I could go. But instead, I wanted to go back home and be with my family for that time.
Kevin Kelly：接下来的几天，我有一种快乐的经历，我对自己说：“好了，如果我只有六个月的时间，我该做什么？”这个问题的答案让我像惊讶于那个任务本身一样感到惊讶，因为深思熟虑之后，我得出的结论是，我想做的事情是回家过平凡的生活，回到父母身边，帮他们倒垃圾，修剪树篱，移动家具，和他们在一起。我对此感到非常震惊，因为我以为如果只剩六个月生命，我会去爬珠穆朗玛峰，或者去深海潜水，或者坐上快艇看看我能开多快。但相反，我只想回家，在那段时间里和家人在一起。
I, of course, did not tell anybody my crazy idea. This is, in fact, the first time I'm really talking about it publicly. Because it's a very scary and alarming idea. And I never told anybody why I was coming home.
Kevin Kelly：当然，我没有告诉任何人我这个疯狂的想法。事实上，这是我第一次真正公开谈论它。因为它是一个非常可怕和惊人的想法。我从没告诉过任何人我为什么回家。
I got back to where my parents live in New Jersey, and things were unbelievably ordinary. And yet, I found myself relishing the ordinariness and finding it in some ways as exotic as anything that I had traveled to see. I helped around the house. I dug up shrubs. I worked on a deck. I moved furniture, washed dishes.
Kevin Kelly：我回到了父母居住的新泽西州，一切都不可思议地平凡。然而，我发现自己很享受这种平凡，在某种程度上，我觉得它和我去过任何地方一样充满异国情调。我帮忙打理家务。我挖掉灌木。我修理甲板。我移动家具，洗碗。
And I was intending to spend my last remaining six months at home getting to know my parents better and myself, hopefully. But about three months into that, my travel urges, I guess, got the better of me. And what I was most concerned about was I wanted to see my brothers and sisters. I had four brothers and sisters. And they were scattered all across the country. And so I felt very strongly that I wanted to see them before I died. And I got the idea that the way to see them was to ride my bicycle across the country and visit them on bicycle.
Kevin Kelly：我打算在家里度过我生命中最后的六个月，更好地了解我的父母，希望也能了解自己。但大约三个月后，我的旅行欲望战胜了我。我最担心的是我想见我的兄弟姐妹。我有四个兄弟姐妹。他们散布在全国各地。所以我强烈地感到在死前想见他们一面。我想到可以通过骑自行车横跨全国的方式去拜访他们。
But before I did that, I made up a will to dispose of the little things that I had. And I had some money left over. And one of the things I did with that money was I went to the bank and got some cashier's checks for $500 and $1,000. And I mailed the money to various people anonymously as gifts. And I think giving away those thousands of dollars was the first true act of charity I had ever done. Because there was absolutely no way for any kind of gratitude or elevated feelings to come back to me, because the people had no idea who had sent them that money.
Kevin Kelly：但在那之前，我立了一份遗嘱来处理我拥有的小物件。我剩下了一些钱。我用这些钱做的一件事是去银行取了一些500美元和1000美元的本票。我匿名把这些钱作为礼物寄给了不同的人。我认为捐出这些数千美元是我做过的第一次真正的慈善行为。因为没有任何感激之情或高尚的情绪能回到我身上，因为那些人根本不知道是谁寄给他们的钱。
It was really remarkable to see the consequences of getting an anonymous gift like that. Because when you get a check for $1,000 in the mail, you immediately become suspicious of all your friends of having given that to you. And so there's this suspicion of charity, suspicion of goodness that starts to infect the people that are around you. And you look at someone, you think, "Hm, I wonder if he gave me that $1,000?"
Kevin Kelly：看到这种匿名馈赠的结果真的很了不起。因为当你收到一张1000美元的支票时，你立刻会怀疑是你所有的朋友送给你的。所以这种对慈善的怀疑、对善意的怀疑开始感染你周围的人。你看着某个人，心想：“嗯，不知道是不是他给了我那1000美元？”
Does that make sense? You look at them, and you think, "I wonder if he gave me that $1,000?" And then you act really nice to him. And then the next person you see, the next of your friends, you think, "Could this be the person?" And then you act really nice to them.
Ira Glass：那有道理吗？你看着他们，心想：“不知道是不是他给了我那1000美元？”然后你对他表现得非常好。接着你看到的下一个人，你的下一个朋友，你心想：“会不会是他？”然后你对他表现得非常好。
I almost want to begin a little speech here about let us all now take up this practice. All of us. Everyone within the sound of my voice. If we all could just do this right now, then I would believe that our little radio show, just 19 minutes into the program, had contributed in some way.
Ira Glass：我几乎想在这里开始一个小演讲，呼吁我们大家都来实践这个做法。我们所有人。在听到我声音的每一个人。如果我们都能现在就做，那么我会相信我们的广播节目，仅仅播出了19分钟，就已经在某种程度上做出了贡献。
I had enough money left over to basically pay for food and whatnot on my bicycle journey across America. And the path that I had to visit all my brothers and sisters was not a direct route, going from San Francisco to New York. I actually had to go up to Idaho, and back down to Texas, and then back up through Indiana. So it was a 5,000 mile trip. The day which, coincidentally, was exactly six months from when I had this assignment, was October 31. It was Halloween. And so the plan would be that I would ride back home, so that I would come back to die on the day after Halloween.
Kevin Kelly：我剩下的钱基本上够支付我横跨美国的自行车旅行的食物和必需品。为了拜访我所有的兄弟姐妹，我走的路线不是直接从旧金山到纽约的。我实际上必须去爱达荷州，再回到德克萨斯州，然后再穿过印第安纳州。所以这是一次5000英里的旅行。那天，巧合的是，距离我接受任务正好六个月，是10月31日。那是万圣节。所以计划是我骑车回家，在万圣节后的第二天死去。
I think there are a lot of people who have trouble staying in the present. There are some people who like to slip into the past as a means to perhaps fantasize or escape. And they find that the past is the place that they retreat to. And I often retreat to the future. I was not a person who planned or had a career staged out, or who had a particular woman he wanted to marry some day, or some vision of a house. The future that I found so hard to give up was a much more insidious type.
Kevin Kelly：我认为很多人都难以活在当下。有些人喜欢逃避到过去，以此作为幻想或逃避的手段。他们发现过去是一个可以退缩的地方。而我经常退缩到未来。我不是那种会做规划或制定职业生涯的人，也没有一个想在某天娶的特定女人，或者对房子的某种愿景。我发现很难放弃的未来是一种更加隐蔽的类型。
It was that of I'd like to buy this record because, in the future, I want to hear this song again and again. Or I will read this book, and there are some cool ideas in it because someday I may write an article about this. And it's good to know that. There was a sense in which my entire life was shifted to the future. And the thought of doing something now for the enjoyment, or the pleasures, or the principle of the function of just right now, without any sense at all that it would ever be used again or that it could ever be brought forward, was extremely difficult and disconcerting. And I fought it day by day and tooth by tooth.
Kevin Kelly：那就是“我想买这张唱片，因为将来我想一次又一次地听到这首歌”。或者“我会读这本书，里面有一些很酷的创意，因为有一天我可能会写一篇关于这个的文章”。这很好，我知道。从某种意义上说，我的整个人生都被转移到了未来。而那种为了享受、乐趣或仅仅是为了当下的功能而做某事，而不觉得它以后会被再次使用，或者它能被带入未来的想法，是极其困难和令人不安的。我一天天地、竭尽全力地与这种心态做斗争。
One of the ways I dealt with this was that I was actually able, by the last weeks, to not think about my life beyond Halloween. There was a way which I had just-- each time a thought came up about something that was beyond this horizon, I just said, "Nope, can't think about it. It doesn't work. We have to dwell in the present."
Kevin Kelly：我应对这种心态的方法之一是，在最后几周，我实际上能够不去想万圣节之后的生活。每当有一个关于超越这个时间范围的想法出现时，我就对自己说：“不，不能想它。那没用。我们必须活在当下。”
And at the same time I was doing that, and I was able to do that, I also decided that it was an entirely unnatural and inhumane way to live. And that having a future is part of what being human is about. And that when you take away the future for humans, you take away a lot of their humanness. And that it's not actually a very good thing to live entirely in the present. That one needs to have a past, and one needs to have a future to be fully human.
Kevin Kelly：与此同时，在我这样做的时候，我同时也认为这是一种完全不自然和不人道的生活方式。拥有未来是身为人类的一部分。当你剥夺了人类的未来，你就剥夺了他们很大一部分人性。完全活在当下并不是一件真正好的事情。一个人需要拥有过去，也需要拥有未来才能成为完整的人。
It was a journey that began at the tomb of Jesus. And as I set off to my own presumed death, I did, indeed, think about Jesus Christ who, according to the Gospels, surrendered his own life in a very knowing way. So we have the history in the Gospels of Jesus's torment in his soul, as he approached what he knew of his anointed time to die. So it was, again, that very harsh information of knowing when you're going to die.
Kevin Kelly：那是一段始于耶稣坟墓的旅程。当我踏上我预期的死亡之旅时，我确实想到了耶稣基督，根据福音书，他以一种非常知情的方式交出了自己的生命。所以我们有福音书中耶稣灵魂受折磨的历史，当他接近他所知的受膏时刻的死亡时。所以，这又是那种知道自己何时会死的极其严酷的信息。
And Jesus's soul was in great turmoil and pain because of knowing that. And I think I did experience some of that, not because I had the same weight. It was just my own life. But Jesus prayed that this burden be lifted, and there were days when I did pray that, that if I didn't have to die, I really would rather not.
Kevin Kelly：耶稣的灵魂因为知道这一点而陷入了极大的动荡和痛苦。我想我确实经历了一些，不是因为我有同样的沉重感。那只是我自己的生活。但耶稣祈求这负担被解除，确实有几天我也这样祈求，如果我不必死，我真的宁愿不死。
By late fall, I was pedaling through the Appalachians, and it was getting colder and colder. And my hands were freezing on the bicycles, and there was ice on my tents in the morning when I got up. And as each day went on, I was coming closer and closer to terrain that I was familiar with and that felt like home. And I was riding into New Jersey, and I was elated. I was elated that I had accomplished this long journey. And I was elated that I was home to see my parents.
Kevin Kelly：到了深秋，我骑车穿过阿巴拉契亚山脉，天气越来越冷。我的手在自行车上冻僵了，我早上起床时帐篷上有冰。随着每一天的推移，我越来越接近我熟悉的、感觉像家一样的地方。我骑车进入新泽西州，我欣喜若狂。我为自己完成了这段漫长的旅程而欣喜若狂。我为回到家见到父母而欣喜若狂。
And I came in to their house on Halloween day. And I was so filled with ideas, and things, and emotions, that I didn't really say very much. And again, I couldn't say very much. I think we had a wonderful dinner. They were, of course, glad to see me because they hadn't seen me in a long time. They knew I was coming back, and we had a wonderful dinner.
Kevin Kelly：我在万圣节那天进入了他们的家。我心中充满了想法、事物和情感，我真的没说太多。而且，我也没法说太多。我想我们吃了一顿美妙的晚餐。他们当然很高兴见到我，因为他们很久没见到我了。他们知道我会回来，我们共进了一顿美妙的晚餐。
We had baskets of candy, which I gave out to the kids. And we had a discussion that night which was about nothing in particular. It was not about the future. It was just about, I think, talking about our family and my brothers and sisters. And I was telling them all that I  had learned about them. And so it was a very together and, again, not a very dramatic evening, but just a pleasant one, one that you might have a memory about as you were dying, which was not a special evening, but just an ordinary evening.
Kevin Kelly：我们有篮子里的糖果，我发给了孩子们。那天晚上我们进行了一次讨论，内容并不具体。不是关于未来。我想只是关于我们的家庭和我的兄弟姐妹。我告诉了他们我所了解的关于他们的一切。这是一个非常亲密、同样不是非常戏剧性，但却很愉快的夜晚，一个你可能会在临终时回忆起的夜晚，那不是一个特别的夜晚，只是一个平凡的夜晚。
And I went to bed that night, which was a very difficult thing to do because I was fully prepared at that point never to wake up again. I had been praying. I had gotten everything arranged. I had fully gone through in my own mind, in my own soul, all the things that I might have regretted. And I had righted as many of those as I thought I could through letters. And I was prepared, as much as anybody could be prepared to die.
Kevin Kelly：那天晚上我去睡觉了，这是一件非常困难的事情，因为那时我已经完全做好了永远不再醒来的准备。我一直在祈祷。我已经安排好了一切。我已经在我的脑海中、在我的灵魂中，彻底审视了我可能后悔的所有事情。我尽可能通过信件纠正了其中的大部分。我已经像任何人可能做到的那样，做好了死亡的准备。
And so I went to bed while the kids were still ringing doorbells. And I went to sleep, because I was very tired after that long trip. And I didn't know what was going to happen the next day. I thought I had done all that I could. And the next morning, I woke up. And the next morning, I woke up, and it was as if-- The next morning I woke up, and it was as if I had the entire-- my entire life again.
Kevin Kelly：于是，当孩子们还在按门铃时，我就去睡觉了。我入睡了，因为在那次长途旅行后我非常累。我不知道第二天会发生什么。我想我已经尽力了。第二天早上，我醒来了。第二天早上，我醒来了，就好像——第二天早上我醒来了，就好像我拥有了完整——我完整的生活又回来了。
The next morning, I woke up, and I had my entire life again. I had my future again. There was nothing special about the day. It was another ordinary day. I was reborn into ordinariness. But what more could one ask for?
Kevin Kelly：第二天早上，我醒来了，我重新拥有了完整的生活。我又有了未来。这一天没有什么特别的。这是又一个平凡的日子。我重生回到了平凡之中。但人们还能要求什么呢？
Well, Kevin Kelly is 43 now. That happened when he was 27. In his latest rebirth, he is the executive editor of Wired magazine, a glossy magazine about the future and the present. He told us that he wasn't even sure he has ever even told his parents this story, even this many years later. Anyway, he spoke with me and Paul Tough from the studios of KQED in San Francisco. This is Your Radio Playhouse on WBEZ Chicago.
Ira Glass：好了，Kevin Kelly现在43岁了。那是他27岁时发生的事。在他的最新重生中，他是《连线》杂志的执行主编，这是一本关于未来和当下的光面杂志。他告诉我们，即使过了这么多年，他不确定是否向父母讲述过这个故事。无论如何，他和来自旧金山KQED工作室的Paul Tough与我进行了交谈。这里是芝加哥WBEZ的《Your Radio Playhouse》。
Good morning. Glass, Jacobson & Associates.
接待员：早上好。Glass, Jacobson & Associates公司。
Hey, is Barry there?
Ira Glass：嘿，Barry在吗？
Pardon me?
接待员：抱歉，你说什么？
Is Barry there?
Ira Glass：Barry在吗？
Yes, he is. He's on another call. Do you wish to hold, or I could take a message, or you can leave one on his voicemail?
Ira Glass：接待员：是的，他在。他正在接听另一个电话。你想留下来等，还是我可以帮你传话，或者你可以在他的语音信箱留言？
It's his son.
Ira Glass：我是他儿子。
Uh-huh.
接待员：嗯。
Isn't this starting to sound like-- this little dialogue-- isn't it starting to sound like an episode of Dr. Katz? You know that TV show? "This is his son." "Uh-huh. Yeah." Anyway, so I thought I would call my parents in Baltimore and ask for advice on this, our first evening of our brand new radio show, Your Radio Playhouse.
Ira Glass：这听起来不是有点像——这一小段对话——不是听起来像《Dr. Katz》的一集吗？你知道那个电视节目吧？“我是他儿子。”“嗯。是的。”总之，我以为我可以打电话给我在巴尔的摩的父母，在这档全新的广播节目《Your Radio Playhouse》的第一晚征求他们的建议。
Can I leave a message with you? Or is it better to use his voicemail?
Ira Glass：我可以留个口信给你吗？还是用他的语音信箱更好？
It doesn't matter. I'll put it right on his voicemail.
接待员：没关系。我会直接把它转进他的语音信箱。
OK, let's do.
Ira Glass：好的，就这样吧。
OK, hold on, please.
接待员：好的，请稍等。
[MUSIC - "NICE 'N' EASY" BY FRANK SINATRA]
接待员：[音乐 - Frank Sinatra的“NICE 'N' EASY”]
This is the story of my childhood right there. Dad is a little too busy to talk. But there's the recording of Frank Sinatra when needed.
Ira Glass：这正是我的童年故事。爸爸忙得没空说话，但有需要时会有Frank Sinatra的录音。
[TELEPHONE RINGING]
Ira Glass：[电话铃响]
Hello?
Shirley Glass：喂？
Hey, Mom.
Ira Glass：嘿，妈。
Oh, hi, Ira.
Shirley Glass：哦，嗨，Ira。
How you doing?
Ira Glass：你怎么样？
Fine. Can you hold on a second?
Shirley Glass：挺好。你能等我一下吗？
Sure.
Ira Glass：当然。
This is what it's like with my parents. They're so busy. Call them. Put on hold. [SINGING] Baby, what's your hurry?
Ira Glass：这就是我父母的样子。他们太忙了。打电话给他们，会被要求保持通话。[唱歌] 宝贝，你为什么这么匆忙？
When I call my little sister, she works at Disney, and so there's Disney music playing on the hold system. But there's a lot of Disney music. And there's a lot of it that peo--
Ira Glass：当我给小妹打电话时，她在Disney工作，所以通话等待时会播放Disney音乐。但Disney音乐太多了，而且其中有很多是人——
Hi.
Shirley Glass：嗨。
Hi, Mom.
Ira Glass：嗨，妈。
Yeah.
Shirley Glass：嗯。
It's me.
Ira Glass：是我。
Yeah.
Shirley Glass：嗯。
Listen, can I record a quick conversation with you about something?
Ira Glass：听着，我可以和你快速录一段关于某件事的对话吗？
What about?
Shirley Glass：关于什么？
Well, you know the new show goes on the air this week. And as part of the show, we were thinking about having me call around to different people and get advice from them. And I wanted to know if you would have any advice.
Ira Glass：嗯，你知道新节目这周就要开播了。作为节目的一部分，我们想让我给不同的人打电话寻求建议。我想知道你有什么建议吗？
Hm. Do I have any advice? Well, can I ask another question?
Shirley Glass：嗯。我有什么建议吗？我可以问个问题吗？
Sure.
Ira Glass：当然。
Who is your target audience?
Shirley Glass：你的目标听众是谁？
You are such a pro.
Ira Glass：你真是个专业人士。
I'm saying that you're in danger of appealing to a narrow range of listeners if it becomes a little too-- I don't know what word to use.
Shirley Glass：我是说，如果节目变得太……我不知道该用什么词，你会有吸引一小部分听众的风险。
Artsy.
Ira Glass：文青气？
Artsy, yeah.
Shirley Glass：文青气，对。
Are you and Dad still worried about me making a living in public radio? I know just for years, you were urging me to just get out and get, basically, any job in TV that I possibly could. But now that I've got my own show, are you guys still worried? Or do you feel like things are going OK? Do you want me to get into television still?
Ira Glass：你和爸爸还在担心我靠公共广播谋生吗？我知道多年来你们一直催我辞职，去找任何能找到的电视工作。但现在我已经有了自己的节目，你们还在担心吗？还是觉得一切都还不错？你们还想让我去搞电视吗？
Now that Hugh Grant is such a big star, and everybody who sees you or sees your picture thinks how much you look like Hugh Grant, that fires up that TV thing again in me.
Shirley Glass：既然Hugh Grant现在是大明星，而且每个看到你或你照片的人都觉得你长得有多像Hugh Grant，这又重新点燃了我对你从事电视工作的念头。
All right. I'm stopping the tape. This is me live. That was the tape. Only my mother could possibly believe this. Only a mother could pretty much believe this. Other adults see me, and the thought that goes through their head is not Hugh Grant. The thought that goes through their head is tall Jew.
Ira Glass：好吧。我要关掉录音了。这是现场的我。刚才那是录音。只有我妈妈才可能相信这个。只有母亲才可能真的相信这个。其他成年人见到我，他们脑海里闪过的念头不是Hugh Grant。他们脑海里闪过的念头是：高个子犹太人。
Well, gosh, wouldn't they want this wonderful humanistic, intelligent reporter who looks like Hugh Grant?
Shirley Glass：哎呀，难道他们不想要这个长得像Hugh Grant、既有人文关怀又聪明的记者吗？
All right. Yeah, let's move on.
Ira Glass：好吧。对，我们继续吧。
What's the theme for this week?
Shirley Glass：这周的主题是什么？
The theme for this week is new beginnings. And we have several stories, people telling about various ways in which their life began anew at some point.
Ira Glass：这周的主题是新的开始。我们有几个故事，人们讲述了他们生活在某个时刻以各种方式重新开始的故事。
That's very interesting, because I just did an interview this morning with a newspaper reporter about roman--
Shirley Glass：这非常有意思，因为我今天早上刚接受了一位报社记者的采访，关于浪漫——
I'm just going to stop the tape again. This is my whole life. I call my mom for an interview, and it's not even her first interview of the day. I was lucky to get a booking. She's a therapist, and sometimes she gets called by the papers and stuff.
Ira Glass：我要再次关掉录音了。这就是我的全部生活。我给妈妈打电话想做个采访，结果这甚至不是她今天的第一场采访。我能预约上真幸运。她是心理治疗师，有时会接到报纸什么的采访。
--mance, romantic love. And people's expectations about relationships. And one of the things I believe is that there are a lot of people who are good at beginnings, but they're not good at middles.
Shirley Glass：——浪漫之爱。以及人们对关系的期望。我相信的一件事是，很多人擅长开始，但不擅长中间过程。
Which means what?
Ira Glass：这意味着什么？
It means that they like the beginning, where there's all this idealization and romantic projections. And the other person can be who they think they should be, rather than who they are. And when they get to the middle phase--
Shirley Glass：这意味着他们喜欢开始阶段，那里充满了理想化和浪漫的投射。对方可以成为他们心目中理想的样子，而不是真实的自己。当他们进入中间阶段——
All right. I'm just going to stop the tape. Listen, all of you in the audience right now, let's just agree right now, it's the very beginning of our relationship. It's the very beginning of our radio relationship right now. This is our little first little radio date, and I just don't want any idealizing on either side. OK? Let's just make eye contact right now. Remember what Joe Franklin said about the eye contact. No idealizing.
Ira Glass：好了。我要关掉录音了。听着，现在台下的所有听众，我们现在就达成一致吧，这是我们关系的开始。这是我们广播关系的开始。这是我们的第一次小广播约会，我不希望双方有任何理想化。好吗？我们现在直视对方。记住Joe Franklin关于目光接触说的话。不要理想化。
--where there's more of a reality-based relationship, they run away from it because it's not as exciting.
Shirley Glass：——当关系变得更加现实时，他们会逃避，因为那没那么令人兴奋。
It's interesting that you say that because, actually, as we've approached the first show, I've realized that I am much more comfortable with the notion of every day, work-a-day radio work, and being on every week, and having pieces on the air. But the notion of saying in a really big way, "OK, this is the beginning. It's the beginning, and we're going to have a big beginning, and we're going to make an epic statement," I feel very uncomfortable with.
Ira Glass：你说这个很有趣，因为实际上，随着第一期节目的临近，我意识到我更适应那种日常、琐碎的广播工作，每周都做，有节目播出。但我对那种大张旗鼓地说“好的，这就是开始。这是一个开始，我们要有一个宏大的开端，我们要发表一个史诗般的宣言”这种概念感到非常不舒服。
So you are good at middles.
Shirley Glass：所以你擅长中间过程。
I'm better, I think, at middles than at beginnings.
Ira Glass：我想我比擅长开始更擅长中间过程。
That's good. That's good because practically all of life is the middle.
Shirley Glass：那很好。那很好，因为生活几乎全都是中间过程。
We have gotten so deep here. I never expected that it was going to get so deep. I'm just very pleased at how deep this has gotten. Now you're sitting there, you're thinking, "Is he making fun of me? What's happening now? Where are you?" No, I'm not. I'm not, actually. I'm not. I'm not. I'm not. You have nothing to worry about.
Ira Glass：我们在这里讨论得太深刻了。我从没想过会变得这么深刻。我很高兴能达到这个深度。你现在坐在那儿，心想：“他在取笑我吗？现在发生了什么？你在哪儿？”不，我没有。真的没有。我没在取笑。你没什么可担心的。
Are we going to get a tape of this since we're outside the Chicago listening area?
Shirley Glass：既然我们在芝加哥收听区域之外，我们能得到一份节目录音吗？
Depending on how you sound, yeah.
Ira Glass：取决于你表现如何，可以。
OK.
Shirley Glass：好吧。
Well, that's my mom, Shirley Glass, speaking to us from Baltimore. I don't think she's going to get a tape. I do not think she's going to get a tape.
Ira Glass：好吧，这就是我的妈妈Shirley Glass，在巴尔的摩接受我们的采访。我不觉得她能拿到录音。我不觉得她能拿到录音。
Well, next on our little playhouse stage, we have Mr. Lawrence Steger. Now those of you who have been listening carefully to our program and taking notes, and I know there are many of you out there, you know what I'm supposed to do at this point. You know because you were listening carefully to Joe Franklin at the very beginning of our program.
Ira Glass：好吧，我们小剧场的下一位嘉宾是Lawrence Steger先生。那些一直认真听节目并做笔记的朋友，我知道你们中有很多，你们知道我此刻该做什么。你们知道，因为你们在节目刚开始时认真听了Joe Franklin的话。
Above all, get the plug fast.
Joe Franklin：最重要的是，快点插播广告。
That's right. Well, thank you, Joe Franklin. Lawrence Steger is a filmmaker and a performance artist, just back from performing in Glasgow, Scotland. He's going back there in January to collaborate with the performance artist, Ron Athey, who lives here in Chicago. And basically, we contacted Lawrence, and we told him the story that you heard over the course of the last half-hour, Kevin Kelly's story, this guy who believes he only has six months to live, goes on this cross-country road trip.
Ira Glass：没错。谢谢你，Joe Franklin。Lawrence Steger是一位电影制作人兼表演艺术家，刚从苏格兰格拉斯哥演出回来。一月份他还要回去，与住在这里的表演艺术家Ron Athey合作。我们联系了Lawrence，告诉了他过去半小时里你听到的那个故事，Kevin Kelly的故事，这个认为自己只剩下六个月寿命的家伙，踏上了横穿国家的公路旅行。
And as it turned out, when Lawrence Steger found out, the day that he found out that he was HIV positive, this was five years ago, on that day, it was the exact day that he and a friend left on a cross-country car trip. So we commissioned him to do a little piece about his experience. And here it is.
Ira Glass：巧的是，当Lawrence Steger发现自己HIV阳性的那天，那是五年前的事了，就在那一天，他和朋友出发去进行跨国车行。所以我们委托他做一段关于他经历的小作品。这就是作品内容。
Title. Road. Treatment. It's shot entirely on video, mostly handheld. Shaky, out of focus, bad color. Overblown color actually. Sort of the way colors are separated on an old television console, yet still has all the outlines of the images repeated. The outlines of the images, the silhouettes, repeated over and over, ad nauseam, and fading into each other.
Lawrence Steger：标题：公路。治疗。完全用视频拍摄，大多是手持的。画面抖动、失焦、色彩糟糕。其实是色彩过饱和。有点像旧电视机上颜色分离的那种感觉，但图像的轮廓依然反复出现。图像的轮廓，剪影，反复出现，令人作呕，并彼此淡入。
Can I get this microphone adjusted a little, so I don't have to lean over so much?
Lawrence Steger：能帮我调一下这个麦克风吗，这样我就不用弯腰这么厉害了？
Yeah, sure. Just pull that.
Ira Glass：好的，当然。拉一下那个。
Check one, two, three. Sound better? Yeah. Sorry. Thanks.
Lawrence Steger：试音，一，二，三。听起来好点了吗？好的。抱歉。谢谢。
Synopsis. The story concerns Luke, gay, white, Midwestern, late twenties. Follows Luke on the day that he is informed of his HIV positive status. Luke cops a stance of cold, brittle, not unlike the Harrison Ford narration on Blade Runner, but there's a hint of vulnerability to Luke.
Lawrence Steger：大纲。故事关于Luke，男同性恋，白人，中西部人，二十多岁。讲述了Luke得知自己HIV阳性的那天。Luke摆出一副冷漠、僵硬的态度，就像《银翼杀手》里Harrison Ford的旁白一样，但Luke身上有一丝脆弱。
Have we got the Harrison Ford or the Rutger Hauer voice?
Lawrence Steger：我们用的是Harrison Ford的声音还是Rutger Hauer的声音？
Yeah.
Ira Glass：好的。
Great. Roll it.
Lawrence Steger：太棒了。开始吧。
Enhance 5719. Track 45 left.
Harrison Ford：强化5719。追踪45左侧。
Great. Take it under me. That's great. Story follows Luke. He's accompanied by his college buddy, Bill, and both are packed for a road trip across the country to San Francisco.
Lawrence Steger：好极了。压过我的声音。太棒了。故事跟随Luke。他的大学好友Bill陪着他，两人都收拾好了行李，准备开车横穿全国去旧金山。
This isn't the right section of Blade Runner. Can you just kill the Blade Runner?
Lawrence Steger：这不是《银翼杀手》合适的部分。你能把《银翼杀手》掐了吗？
Locations. Car interior. Gas station exterior. HIV clinic parking lot. HIV clinic interior. Highway. Music. Strauss's four last songs, particularly "Ruhe, meine Seele!" sung by Dame Janet Baker.
Lawrence Steger：地点。车内。加油站外。HIV诊所停车场。HIV诊所内。高速公路。音乐。Strauss的《最后四首歌》，特别是Dame Janet Baker演唱的《安息吧，我的灵魂！》。
Can you take it under me? Hold.
Lawrence Steger：你能把它压在我声音下面吗？停。
Follows Luke and his friend Bill to the gas station and to the clinic, the last stop before getting on the highway.
Lawrence Steger：跟随Luke和朋友Bill去加油站和诊所，那是上高速公路前的最后一站。
OK. Take it out. Take out the Janet Baker.
Lawrence Steger：好的。撤掉。撤掉Janet Baker的歌。
Bill loads one hits of pot while driving on the way to the gas station and to the clinic.
Lawrence Steger：Bill在去加油站和诊所的路上吸大麻。
Can we nix that Strauss music? It's too mournful. There's really no music on the soundtrack. It's stark, crisp. Maybe some songs coming from the radio at the clinic's desk?
Lawrence Steger：能把Strauss的音乐撤掉吗？太哀伤了。原声带里其实没有任何音乐。它是冷峻、干脆的。也许诊所前台的收音机里可以传出一些歌？
[RADIO STATIC]
Lawrence Steger：[收音机杂音]
Great. And definitely from the car radio mixed with surfing on an AM radio. No music.
Ira Glass：太棒了。绝对要从车内收音机传来，混杂着AM收音机的调频声。没有音乐。
The drama is constantly being undermined through the cool, collective quality of Luke's demeanor. He seems detached, quote, "I am not sure how I feel. I feel a little sad, sort of mad. I guess blank. But I'm OK. I'm sure I'll get a handle on it," end quote. Luke thinks he's sounding like a short story assignment in a creative writing class or, worse, trapped inside an artsy novel.
Ira Glass：这种戏剧性不断被Luke冷酷、集体化的态度所削弱。他显得疏离，引用：“我不确定我的感受。我感觉有点难过，有点生气。我想是一片空白。但我还好。我相信我会处理好的，”引用结束。Luke觉得自己的声音听起来像创意写作课上的短篇小说作业，或者更糟，被困在了一部文青小说里。
Luke imagines himself in a television dramatization of himself. Camera pulls back from behind Luke's head, sort of on a mini-crane. Camera floats, hovers over the back of Luke's head. "The ceiling of the car must be incredibly high," he thinks to himself.
Ira Glass：Luke想象自己处在关于他自己的电视改编剧中。摄像机从Luke脑后拉开，像是在小型摇臂上。摄像机漂浮着，悬停在Luke脑后。他心想：“车顶一定高得离谱。”
Bill pulls into the closest parking spot in the clinic, blows out the last of the one-hit, and, as he's knocking the brass pipe into the ashtray, turns to Luke with that slightly watery look in his eyes from too much intake. Luke takes it as one of those Care Bear looks that he's experienced before from Bill. A little clumsy since Bill has to force his face into a sympathetic posture. Quick close-up on the corner of Bill's mouth.
Ira Glass：Bill把车停在诊所最近的车位，吐出最后一口大麻烟，当他把黄铜烟斗磕进烟灰缸时，转头看着Luke，眼神因为吸食过量而略显湿润。Luke觉得那是他以前从Bill那里感受过的“爱心熊”式的眼神。有点笨拙，因为Bill不得不强迫自己的脸摆出同情的姿势。特写镜头快速切到Bill嘴角的肌肉。
There's a moment of anger flashing in Luke when he registers Bill's look. When Bill asks him, "What are you thinking about?" Luke responds, "Who's thinking? Nothing." "I hate thinking I'm in a novel," he thinks to himself. Cut to interior of the clinic, the reception area.
Ira Glass：当Luke注意到Bill的眼神时，他闪过一丝愤怒。当Bill问他：“你在想什么？”Luke回答说：“谁在想？什么也没想。”“我讨厌觉得自己身处小说中，”他心想。切到诊所内部，接待区。
Can we change this sound bed here?
Ira Glass：我们能换一下这里的背景音吗？
[ROMANTIC MUSIC PLAYING]
Ira Glass：[播放浪漫音乐]
Great. Take it down just a-- Great.
Ira Glass：好极了。音量降一点——好的。
In the scene that we talked about on the phone, the clinic waiting room scene, that scene flips back and forth between various security black-and-white cameras mounted at the ceilings. The nurse assigned to Luke's anonymous number is a black drag queen named Stephanie, who wears a full nurse's outfit complete with a little paper hat that sits atop of her freshly coiffed hairdo. She's the only one in the clinic who wears a real uniform. Stephanie has the longest fingernails that Luke has ever seen on anyone. Luke thinks briefly about how the fingernails keep on growing even after a person dies, but he pushes that thought away with this fingers to his forehead, wonders why he is thinking about that. It's that novel thing again.
Ira Glass：在我们在电话里谈到的那个场景，诊所候诊室的场景，那个场景在安装在天花板上的各种监控摄像头之间来回切换。分配给Luke匿名编号的护士是一位名叫Stephanie的黑人变装皇后，她穿着全套护士装，头顶戴着一顶小纸帽，压在她刚梳理好的发型上。她是诊所里唯一穿真正制服的人。Stephanie有着Luke见过的人中最长的指甲。Luke短暂地想了一下，人死后指甲还会继续生长，但他用手指按住额头把这个想法赶走了，纳闷自己为什么会想这个。又是那种小说情节。
Stephanie, the drag queen nurse, walks Luke back to the small cubicles that the tests are administered in and then used to relay the results. Luke's narrator imagines how many people have been in these cubicles and what they would look like if they were all piled on top of one another. Piles of tested bodies. Cut to Stephanie closing the hollow core door, makes that hollow core door sound.
Ira Glass：变装皇后护士Stephanie带着Luke回到进行测试的小隔间，那里也用于传达结果。Luke的旁白想象着有多少人曾在这个隔间里，如果他们全部堆在一起会是什么样子。一堆测试过的身体。切到Stephanie关上空心门，发出那种空心门关上的声音。
Do we have that on cart?
Ira Glass: 我们有那个磁带吗？
[SOUND OF HOLLOW DOOR CLOSING]
Ira Glass: [空心门关上的声音]
Perfect. Maybe a shot from a security camera that shows all of the cubicles in the clinic. Luke imagines himself in a George Tooker painting that was reproduced in his sixth grade reader. He wonders what his sixth grade teacher would think of Stephanie. He wonders if his sixth grade teacher was ever tested. He imagines her body in the pileup of bodies who have come to the clinic.
Ira Glass: 完美。也许可以用一个安全摄像头的镜头，展示诊所里所有的隔间。Luke 想象自己置身于一幅乔治·塔克（George Tooker）的画作中，那幅画曾印在他六年级的教材上。他想知道他六年级的老师会怎么看 Stephanie。他想知道他六年级的老师是否曾接受过检测。他想象着她的身体也堆叠在那些来到诊所的人堆中。
Stephanie has been saying something, and Luke has to blink his eyes again to refocus. He explains to Stephanie that he has been expecting this result, that he's experienced a large share of AIDS, cared for, and, likewise, buried lots of his friends. But it doesn't seem to come as a surprise. Stephanie says, "You can cry or hold my hand. I just want you to sit for a moment and let it sink in." Luke thinks, "Whatever."
Ira Glass: Stephanie 一直在说些什么，Luke 不得不再次眨眼以重新聚焦。他向 Stephanie 解释说，他一直预料到会有这个结果，他经历过很多艾滋病病例，照顾过，也同样埋葬过许多朋友。但这似乎并没有让他感到意外。Stephanie 说：“你可以哭，或者握住我的手。我只想让你坐一会儿，消化一下。”Luke 心想：“随它去吧。”
Cut to Bill in waiting room, flipping through People 's The Year in Pictures. Cut back to close-up of Luke, forehead wrinkled. He thinks his narrator wants him to get out of the cubicle. He waits for Stephanie to finish her spiel, thanks her, and shakes her hand, getting a slight scrape from one of the fingernails. Close-up on Luke's hand, no scratch. The walls seem to pulsate as Luke walks down the hallway to the reception area. He tries to be as blank as possible to Bill.
Ira Glass: 切到候诊室里的 Bill，正在翻看《人物》杂志的《年度图片》。切回 Luke 的特写，额头紧皱。他觉得他的叙述者想让他离开那个隔间。他等 Stephanie 说完那一套话，感谢她并与她握手，指甲被其中一个指甲轻轻划了一下。Luke 手部的特写，没有划痕。当 Luke 穿过走廊走向接待处时，墙壁似乎在跳动。他尽量在 Bill 面前表现得面无表情。
I'm not sure about this final section. I know that we talked about it ending on the highway with the car being surrounded by bikers on their way to the Sturgis bikers' rally. But now I like the idea of it ending on the highway entrance ramp.
Ira Glass: 我对这最后一部分不太确定。我知道我们讨论过以高速公路上车子被赶往斯特吉斯（Sturgis）摩托车集会的骑手们包围作为结尾。但现在我更倾向于以高速公路入口匝道作为结局。
Cut to interior of car pulling out of parking lot. Luke keeps looking straight ahead, as he murmurs, "I'm positive." Long, slow pan from the back of Luke's head to the back of Bill's. There's no reaction in either of their faces or, better, the profiles of their faces. This is the longest shot. They don't look at each other.
Ira Glass: 切到车内，车子驶出停车场。Luke 始终直视前方，喃喃自语道：“我是阳性。”镜头缓慢地从 Luke 的后脑勺平移到 Bill 的后脑勺。他们的脸上，或者更准确地说是他们的侧脸，没有任何反应。这是最长的一个镜头。他们没有看对方。
Perhaps this scene would be shot in blue screen with the camera in the backseat and the sky surrounding the two heads of Bill and Luke having that old, scratchy, 16 millimeter time lapse exposure, so the clouds seem to be moving at a rapid pace. Flickers, flips back and forth between real sky and blue screen backdrop. Voice comes up on a car radio. "Trying not to think of the future. Just live in the present moment." Something like that. You got that? It comes onto the radio.
Ira Glass: 也许这场戏可以用蓝幕拍摄，摄像机放在后座，Bill 和 Luke 两个人的头周围是天空，带有那种旧式、颗粒感的 16 毫米延时曝光效果，让云层看起来移动得很快。在真实天空和蓝幕背景之间闪烁、交替。车载收音机里传出声音。“试着不去想未来。只活在当下。”类似这样的话。你听到了吗？它在收音机里响起。
I also decided that it was an entirely unnatural and inhumane way to live, and that having a future is part of what being human is about, and that when you take away the future for humans, you take away a lot of the humanness, and that it's not actually a very good thing to live entirely in the present, that one needs to have a past.
Kevin Kelly: 我也认定那是一种完全不自然、不人道的生活方式，拥有未来是身为人类的一部分，当你剥夺了人类的未来，你就剥夺了很大一部分人性。事实上，完全活在当下并不是一件好事，人需要拥有过去。
Luke comments to Bill, "Live entirely in the present, huh?" Bill drives and looks out the corner of his right eye to see what position Luke is holding his head in. Luke looks outside passenger window and, every once in a while, turns to glance at Bill. Long pause. There's dead air. Cut to Luke's point of view. Car is pulling onto entrance ramp of highway. Luke sees hitchhiker with a sign that he stands for any remote meaning to the narrative. Luke sees himself outside of his own story. He can't read the hitchhiker's sign. He knows that he's on a long silent journey. He leans over to turn off the radio. Cut to black.
Lawrence Steger: Luke 对 Bill 评论道：“完全活在当下，哈？”Bill 开着车，用右眼余光瞥了一眼，观察 Luke 头部的姿势。Luke 看着乘客车窗外，偶尔转过头瞥一眼 Bill。长时间的停顿。一片死寂。切到 Luke 的视角。车子正驶上高速公路的入口匝道。Luke 看到一个搭便车的人举着一个牌子，他觉得那个牌子代表了叙事中任何遥远的含义。Luke 在自己的故事之外看到了自己。他无法读懂搭车人牌子上的字。他知道自己正在进行一段漫长的沉默旅程。他俯身关掉了收音机。切成黑色。
[MUSIC - "(UH-OH) GET OUT OF THE CAR" BY THE TRENIERS]
Lawrence Steger: [音乐 - THE TRENIERS 的 “(UH-OH) GET OUT OF THE CAR”]
Well, Lawrence Steger is a Chicago performance artist and filmmaker.
Ira Glass: 好的，Lawrence Steger 是一位芝加哥表演艺术家和电影制作人。
This is Your Radio Playhouse. I'm Ira Glass. OK, what am I doing right now? What am I doing right now? That's right. That's right. Eye contact.
Ira Glass: 这里是《你的广播剧场》（Your Radio Playhouse）。我是 Ira Glass。好了，我现在在做什么？我现在在做什么？没错。没错。眼神接触。
Look right in the eye. Eye contact is everything.
Joe Franklin: 直视眼睛。眼神接触就是一切。
That's right. Advice from the master. OK. Let's review our program so far. Let's just review. Let's just get things straight right now. Our stories so far have been about people whose futures were taken from them and were thrown into the present in one way or another.
Ira Glass: 没错。来自大师的建议。好了。让我们回顾一下目前的节目。让我们来复习一下。让我们现在把事情理清楚。我们目前的故事都是关于那些未来被剥夺、以某种方式被抛入现实生活中的人们。
I guess when any big emotional moment happens, you are thrown in the present in a really aggressive, aggressive way, whether you choose to or not. You have this hyper sense of reality. Well, the next story is about someone whose future was taken from him when he was wrongly imprisoned for 20 years. And his sentence was commuted two years ago. And he found himself reborn into everyday life.
Ira Glass: 我想当任何重大的情绪时刻发生时，你都会以一种非常强烈的、极具侵略性的方式被抛入现实中，无论你是否愿意。你会有一种超现实感。那么，下一个故事是关于一个被错误监禁了 20 年，从而失去了未来的人。他的刑期在两年前被减免了。他发现自己重生回到了日常生活。
It was like I just-- I don't know. It seemed like the oxygen was even different. You know what I mean? The air seemed to be thinner.
Ed Ryder: 感觉就像我刚刚——我不知道。似乎连氧气都不一样了。你明白我的意思吗？空气似乎变稀薄了。
I'll tell you what's been a real kick for me, getting up, cooking breakfast. Making pancakes, and eggs, and bacon, and stuff like that. It sounds drab maybe to the common-- everybody would think of that as, "That's really drab." But for me, that's really exciting. And that's one of the things I always dreamed of doing. I also dreamt of finding a very lovely lady, and I have. Inside, I'm happy. Inside.
Ed Ryder: 我告诉你什么事对我来说特别带劲，那就是起床，做早餐。做煎饼、鸡蛋、培根之类的东西。对普通人来说，这听起来可能很枯燥——每个人都会觉得，“那太无聊了。”但对我来说，这非常令人兴奋。那是我一直梦想做的事情之一。我还梦想找到一位可爱的女士，我也找到了。内心深处，我很幸福。内心深处。
This is Ed Ryder. He was in prison for murder and was doing time in Graterford Prison in Pennsylvania. And a few years ago, a key witness who had testified against him admitted to lying while under oath, and other evidence came forward. He was made a free man. Back when he was in Graterford Prison, he played trumpet, and he sang with a jazz band. And that whole time, he dreamed of this new life, a new life that he would have outside as a professional musician. And that's what he's working on. That's what he's working on right now. And he's playing. He doesn't have a CD yet, but he's playing gigs in the real world.
Ira Glass: 这位是 Ed Ryder。他因谋杀罪入狱，在宾夕法尼亚州的格雷特福德（Graterford）监狱服刑。几年前，一位曾出庭指控他的关键证人承认自己在宣誓后撒了谎，其他证据也浮出水面。他获得了自由。当他在格雷特福德监狱时，他吹小号，并与一支爵士乐队一起唱歌。在那段漫长的时光里，他梦想着这种新生活，一种他在外面作为职业音乐家可以拥有的新生活。而这就是他正在努力的事情。这就是他现在正在做的事情。他在演奏。他还没有 CD，但他正在真实世界里进行演出。
The first time I played, when I got out of prison, I didn't feel compelled to be so exact like I did when I was at Graterford. Inmates are the worst, critical people in the world. They criticize anything you do. In prison, you have a lot of musicians. After all, musicians, they don't make no money, so I guess the first place you find them at is in prison. But you have a lot of guys who are musicians.
Ed Ryder: 我出狱后第一次演奏时，我并没有感到像在格雷特福德时那样必须精确。囚犯是世界上最刻薄的批评家。他们批评你做的任何事情。在监狱里，你有很多音乐家。毕竟，音乐家赚不到钱，所以我猜你在监狱里最容易找到他们。但你确实有很多是音乐家的人。
And even though they might not be actively playing anymore, they'll be quick to criticize you, whether the chord is not right, or whether you didn't flatten the ninth, whether you didn't raise this fifth, or you guys didn't play the changes right. Although it might not have took away from the structure of the music, it's just that, I guess you can say that prisoners have a tendency to think like classical musicians would. Everything has to be perfect and exact the way it's heard. And everything has to be like that. There's no going against the grain.
Ed Ryder: 即使他们可能不再积极演奏了，他们也会很快批评你，说和弦不对，或者你没有降九音，或者你没有升高五音，或者你们这群人没有把变奏弹对。虽然这可能并没有损害音乐的结构，但我猜你可以说，囚犯往往会像古典音乐家那样思考。一切都必须完美且精确，就像听到的那样。一切都必须那样。没有反其道而行之的可能。
And here, in the world, people are a little different. They don't concern themselves so much with that, as much as how are you entertaining us? How are you helping us to feel better about ourselves? How are you making us feel better? At Graterford, there is nothing you can do to make them feel better, except to release them.
Ed Ryder: 而在这里，在现实世界中，人们有点不同。他们不太关心那些，更多关心的是你如何娱乐我们？你如何帮助我们感觉更好？你如何让我们感到快乐？在格雷特福德，你做任何事都无法让他们感觉更好，除非释放他们。
So if you can play for a Graterford audience, you don't even look for an applause. Just as long as they don't boo you, you're all right. If they can't find nothing wrong with the music, they'll tell you, "You just didn't turn right. When you had the horn up, you didn't hold it on a 45 degree angle. It didn't look right." So they'll find something.
Ed Ryder: 所以如果你能在格雷特福德的观众面前演奏，你甚至不必期待掌声。只要他们不嘘你就行了。如果他们找不到音乐的任何毛病，他们会告诉你：“你转得不对。当你举起号角时，你没有保持 45 度角。看起来不对。”所以他们总会找到点什么的。
Now you know how we heard people earlier in the program talk about the importance of living in the present. But when we interviewed Ed Ryder, he pointed out that, in prison, the most important thing is to keep your eye on the future, on the day that you're going to get out. And that the guys who just live in the present do really badly, because, of course, the present is so terrible.
Ira Glass: 现在你知道为什么我们节目早些时候听到人们谈论活在当下的重要性了。但当我们采访 Ed Ryder 时，他指出在监狱里，最重要的事情是盯着未来，盯着你出狱的那一天。那些只活在当下的人过得很惨，因为当然了，现实是非常可怕的。
I think when I was in prison, I dreamed more about the future in my head. I just had a lot of plans, a lot of things that I just dreamed about, I just dreamed of doing and dreamed of accomplishing. You're forced almost to. You know what I mean? You have nothing else to look forward to but tomorrow. You're constantly hoping and hoping. You're trying to plan something for the future.
Ed Ryder: 我想在监狱里时，我在脑海里更多地梦想未来。我有很多计划，很多我只是梦想着去做、梦想着去实现的事情。你几乎是被迫这样做的。你明白我的意思吗？除了明天，你没有什么可期待的。你不断地怀揣希望。你试图为未来计划些什么。
We asked him if he is still playing the same music now that his future is here and he's out. And we thought that maybe the songs that he used to play would just bring back these hard memories of prison that he'd rather just as soon avoid. But he said, no, he plays the same numbers now that he used to, though sometimes they mean something different to him today.
Ira Glass: 我们问他，既然未来已来且他已重获自由，他是否还在演奏同样的音乐。我们原以为他过去演奏的歌曲会带回那些他宁愿避免的关于监狱的痛苦回忆。但他表示，不，他现在依然演奏同样的曲目，尽管今天这些曲子对他来说有着不同的意义。
When I was in Graterford, I always listened to it. I had a tape of "God Bless the Child That's Got His Own" by Billie Holiday. And what it meant to me when I was at Graterford-- and it has the same meaning now, but it's different. In the sense that, when I was at Graterford, when she said, "Them that's got shall get, Them that's not shall lose. So the Bible says, and it still is news. Mama may have, Papa may have, But God bless the child that has his own."
Ed Ryder: 当我在格雷特福德时，我总是听它。我有一盘 Billie Holiday 的《God Bless the Child That's Got His Own》的磁带。当我在格雷特福德时，它对我意味着什么——它现在的意义还是一样，但又有所不同。从某种意义上说，当我在格雷特福德时，当她唱道：“富者愈富，穷者愈贫。圣经如是说，这依然是新闻。妈妈可能有，爸爸可能有，但愿上帝保佑拥有自己一切的孩子。”
Well, in my mind, at Graterford, I thought that, yes, I was the child that had his own, because I was out here on my own. I had no help at the time. There was no hope. I seen no way. I was like a child. I was like a child because I had no one I can turn to. My parents had passed. I had no one I could turn to.
Ed Ryder: 那么，在我心中，在格雷特福德时，我想，是的，我就是那个拥有自己一切的孩子，因为我在外面独自一人。当时我没有帮助。没有希望。我看不到出路。我就像个孩子。我就像个孩子，因为我没有任何人可以求助。我的父母已经去世了。我没有任何人可以依靠。
And I felt like every time I would listen to that, I felt as though she was talking directly to me. And for me, that meant that I was on my own in this prison situation. And I was going to have to make it the best way that I could. And I was going to have to muster all the energy that I could possibly muster. Now when I was released and I heard the same song again, it still had that meaning, but now it's a different-- I'm on my own differently because I'm not in prison anymore.
Ed Ryder: 我觉得每次听那首歌，都觉得她好像是在直接对我说话。对我来说，这意味着在这种监狱环境下我是靠自己。我必须尽我所能活下去。我必须鼓起我所能鼓起的所有力量。现在当我获释后再次听到这首歌，它依然有那种含义，但现在它变成了另一种——我以一种不同的方式靠自己，因为我不再在监狱里了。
That's not the struggle no more. It's me. But I'm on my own now because I've got things that I have to do. I have responsibilities now that I have to take care of. I have bills that I have to pay. I have job responsibility.
Ed Ryder: 那不再是挣扎。那是我。但我现在靠自己，是因为我有必须要做的事情。我有责任要承担。我有账单要付。我有工作责任。
I have a lot of other things that I have to do, and I have to do these things on my own now. I don't have no prison guards waking me up in the morning, telling me, "Hey, it's time to get up," or "It's time to go eat, " or "It's time where you guys can go to a shower." I don't have that anymore. I'm on my own. So all this now is dependent upon me and my own initiative.
Ed Ryder: 我还有很多其他必须要做的事情，我现在必须靠自己去做这些事。没有狱警早上叫醒我，告诉我“嘿，起床了”，或者“该去吃饭了”，或者“现在是你们去洗澡的时候了”。我不再有这些了。我靠自己。所以现在这一切都取决于我自己和我的主动性。
[SINGING] Them that's got shall get, them that's not will lose. So the Bible said, and it still is news. Mama may have, Papa may have, but God bless the child that's got his own, that's got his own. You know the strong get more, while the weak ones fade. Empty pockets don't, they don't make the grade. Mama may have, Papa may have, but God bless the child that's got his own, that's got his own. Money, you've got lots of friends. They all keep hanging around your door. But when money's gone and all of the spendings end, they don't come around, they won't come around no more. Rich relations give a crust of bread and such. Go on and help yourself, but you better not take too much. Mama may have, Papa may have, but God bless the child that's got his own. God bless the child that's got his own.
Ed Ryder: [唱歌] 富者愈富，穷者愈贫。圣经如是说，这依然是新闻。妈妈可能有，爸爸可能有，但愿上帝保佑拥有自己一切的孩子，那是拥有自己一切的。你知道强者得到更多，而弱者逐渐凋零。空口袋不能，不能达标。妈妈可能有，爸爸可能有，但愿上帝保佑拥有自己一切的孩子，那是拥有自己一切的。金钱，你有很多朋友。他们都围着你的门口转。但当钱花光了，消费结束了，他们就不会再来了，他们再也不会来了。富有的亲戚会给一块面包之类的东西。去拿吧，帮助自己，但你最好别拿太多。妈妈可能有，爸爸可能有，但愿上帝保佑拥有自己一切的孩子。上帝保佑拥有自己一切的孩子。
That's basically some of it.
Ed Ryder: 基本就是这样。
Ed Ryder joining us in the playhouse from the studios of WHYY in Philadelphia, speaking with me and associate producer Nancy Updike. Ed Ryder's a big Billie Holiday fanatic. That was the word he used, "fanatic," when we asked him about it. So when we asked him to play a number with his horn, with his trumpet, he played "Lover Man."
Ira Glass: Ed Ryder 从费城 WHYY 工作室加入我们的剧场，与我和助理制作人 Nancy Updike 对话。Ed Ryder 是 Billie Holiday 的超级狂热粉丝。这是我们问起他时他自己用的词，“狂热”。所以当我们请他用号角，也就是小号演奏一首曲子时，他演奏了《Lover Man》。
[MUSIC - "LOVER MAN" BY BILLIE HOLIDAY]
Ira Glass: [音乐 - BILLIE HOLIDAY 的 “LOVER MAN”]
That's pretty much all the time we have for this evening.
Ira Glass: 今晚的时间差不多了。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
Ira Glass: [资助鸣谢]
This show was produced by Dolores Wilber, Peter Clowney, Nancy Updike, Alix Spiegel, and myself. Contributing editors Paul Tough and Jack Hitt on the west coast, Margy Rochlin on the east coast. I've got that backwards. Paul Tough and Jack Hitt on the east coast. Margy Rochlin on the west. You see, you get so confused when you have two pieces of music running at the same time.
Ira Glass: 本节目由 Dolores Wilber、Peter Clowney、Nancy Updike、Alix Spiegel 和我自己制作。西海岸的特约编辑是 Paul Tough 和 Jack Hitt，东海岸是 Margy Rochlin。我弄反了。西海岸是 Paul Tough 和 Jack Hitt。东海岸是 Margy Rochlin。你看，当同时播放两段音乐时，你会变得非常混乱。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
Ira Glass: [致谢]
Torey Malatia has supported this show from the start. We'll be back next week, same time, we hope. From WBEZ Chicago, I'm Ira Glass.
Ira Glass: Torey Malatia 从一开始就支持这个节目。我们希望下周同一时间再见。来自芝加哥 WBEZ，我是 Ira Glass。